how many americans american citizens
remain in
in afghanistan i don't know i think as
you probably know
first of all the state department would
be a better place to go for an estimate
of how many americans are afghanistan
well we've seen a lot of the pentagon
briefings lately for the latest on the
situation in afghanistan let's bring in
pentagon press secretary john kirby
admiral kirby thanks for joining us
thank you brett
the president said that the
administration had planned for every
contingency in the interview with george
stephanopoulos yesterday are you aware
aware of any plans that involved several
thousand americans left to fend for
themselves outside of security zones
through the taliban to get to the
airport in the contingency well we
certainly did plan for a non-combatant
evacuation brett in fact planning began
for that as far back as early may
now we didn't know exactly what the
conditions were going to be like and as
you heard
the chairman of the joint chiefs of
staff say yesterday there was nothing
that we had seen that would indicate a
total collapse of the government
in 11 days and as fast as it was but
even two weeks ago brett we did a
tabletop exercise here at the pentagon
to further refine what would be what
were ended up
us executing which is a non-combatant
evacuation out of hamid karzai
international airport obviously look
this is a very fluid situation remains
very fluid things certainly happen
faster than we anticipated they would
they would happen but luckily we had
pre-positioned forces already in the
region and closer to
afghanistan to be able to get them there
in just a matter of hours
yeah i asked you right before we went on
whether you'd seen this new wall street
journal reporting which we've now
confirmed two dozen state department uh
employees at the embassy sending a memo
to secretary of state blinken saying
that they believe the taliban would
quickly take over soon after the august
31st deadline and that they were really
concerned about evacuation uh and how
that was going to go you have no
knowledge of that or that it was in
intel reports i i i certainly wouldn't
talk about intel and i don't know
anything about that cable but what i can
tell you here is at the pentagon you
know certainly we were watching with
alarm as uh district after district and
then provincial capital after provincial
capital began to fall to the taliban and
we realized this was unfolding uh very
very quickly i have not seen that cable
though so i can't attest to the validity
of it
yeah
obviously there's a lot of critics on
both sides of the aisle and there'll be
a lot of time as the chairman of the
joint chiefs said to do after action
reports your main concern is to get
people out but senator tom cotton is
concerned about that specifically too
here's what he said
if our government can't even say how
many american citizens we have what's
going to stop joe biden from rolling up
things and flying out on august 31st
with thousands of american citizens left
behind what increasingly worries me is
the scenario of tehran in 1979 when 52
hostages held by the ayatollah paralyzed
american foreign policy for more than a
year imagine if the taliban has
effective hostage control of thousands
of americans who are stranded in
afghanistan
so react to that if you can well
certainly nobody wants to see a replay
of what happened in iran back in the
late 70s bret where uh you know we we
know we know what happened we understand
that history what i can tell you right
now is that we have a safe and secure
airport it is it is operating uh and we
are in charge of running the operation
there we also have uh uh
community communication with the taliban
to allow americans uh through their
checkpoints and onto
onto the facility we we don't know of
any major disruption to that i can't i
can't say with perfect uh you know uh
validity that there isn't a case here
and there where an american might be
having a having trouble but by and large
uh we are getting americans in through
their checkpoints and onto the airfield
for further on flow in fact you know
hundreds more americans uh have left
today so we are still working this very
very hard very very closely and as
secretary austin said yesterday our goal
is to get as many people out as fast as
we can
yeah but is there a deal with the
taliban that restricts u.s forces to
the airport
no
there's no deal that restricts uh forces
to the airport but brett that's where
the mission is
the the troops are there for really two
things one to keep that airport safe and
secure for people and for flight
operations and two to make sure that
those flight operations can go as
unimpeded as possible with this few
delays as many aircraft as we can get
but if the british if the british can
take their paratroopers and they can get
in vehicles and go get their people and
get them to the airport why can't the
u.s do that if there is a deal with the
taliban to provide safe passage why is
it left to the americans outside of that
ring
to get there on their own why can't we
send vehicles to go get them we we we
have not seen uh any great impediments
uh to the safe passage that the taliban
have agreed to facilitate americans are
getting through those checkpoints and
they are getting on to the base on the
airfield and they are being flown out of
kabul i won't speak to potential future
operations that may or may not be
conducted what i can tell you is the
operation we're conducting now and that
is to keep that airfield open and
running and americans are getting
through the lines they are getting onto
planes
does the us military con consider the
taliban an enemy
uh we're our focus right now uh the the
thing we're we're working against right
now is is time and space and we want to
get as many people out of kabul as we
can uh in as little amount of time as we
can there are no hostile interactions
right now between american forces and
the taliban and we want to keep it that
way
okay and we hope it does stay that way
we appreciate you coming on and
answering questions we'll have you back
thanks brett hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else